when you're trying to sell a product
um a new product what are the words that
Madison Avenue finds are the most
helpful they're two one is new and the
second is free so we're going to give
you something for free and it's going to
be new people love things that are new
and so that's to some extent that's part
of the appeal of crypto it's new it's
different and younger people tend to
like newer things older people people my
age and older they tend to say well I
know what I know from my life
experiences I don't want to try
something new because I don't unfully
understand it so the people pushing
cryptocurrencies and and related things
are not generally people in their 70s or
80s they're probably people in their 20s
or 30s I interviewed for my TV show the
other day Sam bankman freed who you
probably know of he's a 30 year old who
I think had at one point a Fortune of
about 20 some billion dollars that's
maybe down a little bit now you know
he's probably typical of many of the
people in that generation who are
younger they're willing to try things
they they can afford to fail and then
pick themselves up because they're so
young again and start life all over
again he hasn't failed but I I think
young people are the ones who lead Revel
Illusions young people are the ones who
pursue things like uh you know the
current take smartphones or take um uh
personal computers it was young people
that kind of pushed that for social
media young people that kind of pushed
that you rarely see revolutionary
companies being started by people in
their 70s or 80s when you interview
somebody like Sam bankman freed who will
put them in the category of young
billionaire successful with new
technology you also have interviewed
people who were exactly like him just
later in their career and so whether
that's the Jeff bezos's or the Bill
Gates or whoever they are and I always
say that you know uh if the young
Challenger lives long enough they become
the incumbent right in some ways Bill
Gates was trying to take on uh the
incumbents and now he has become the
incumbent what are the similarities and
differences that you see in some of the
young people today versus the what
you're seeing in the successful
billionaires who now are in their 40s
50s and 60s well in my generation uh
younger people were not as focused on
making Fortune uh and there was no there
were no private Equity firms when I
graduated from college there was no
we're virtually none uh there were no
hedge funds or virtually none and now
more and more people in my generation uh
when they were called in public service
by President Kennedy and his famous
inaugural addressed and things like that
people wanted to change the war in
Vietnam or things like that now people
when they go to college when they want
to do if they even want to stay and
graduate they want to go out and start a
business they don't want to go change
the world necessarily they want to start
a business make some money you know I
think the ideal for a lot of people is
to become a billionaire when you're 30
and then do whatever you want with the
rest of your life it's not that easy to
do but I I do think that more and more
younger people are attracted to business
and entrepreneurial activities than than
was the case 20 or 30 or 40 years ago
hey you you did you like this video
great make sure you subscribed like the
video and see you next time